So we've almost made it through science.
Now we've discovered that science is really a foundation
for understanding our world
and it does not contradict our faith.
Well, that's good news.
We've also taken a look at three really good pieces
of evidence that help us see that God is actually there,
that we have evidence for God.
We looked at the idea of fine-tuning.
We looked at the idea of DNA
and we looked at the idea of design.
All of these pointing to God in some way, shape, or form
through the use of science.
Now, I want you to keep in mind
two kinds of students this week.
The first kind is the student that has all this information
and is super fired up
and ready to go with the best arguments
that they have to their teacher
who probably knows more than they do
about all these things,
especially this week with the idea of design
because this is where the conversation
between creation and evolution starts to really come alive.
And it might seem like this is a good idea
for them to jump off and start all these arguments
and try to win people to Christ
and they might try it and you want to champion that
but at the same time make sure that they do so
in truth and love.
That if they're gonna have these conversations
you don't want to tell them not to
and it's okay that they can challenge their teachers
and it's okay to challenge their students
but to do so with love
and to do so with the appropriate amount of respect
especially for teachers
as well as engaging in the right kinds of conversations.
Now, the other type of student
is maybe the one that really is still not sure
or the one that wasn't sure
before entering into this conversation.
Now would be a really good time
to just take a step back and take inventory
with that student and ask them the plain question.
Was this enough evidence?
Do you need more?
What further questions do you have?
What clarifications do you need?
Now remember the reason why we're doing this study.
It's so that our students can have a deep conviction
for themselves about what they believe
and why they believe it.
And to also be able to communicate that
in love and humility and do so relationally.
So while it might be really exciting
to have some eager students to get started
and to get engaged in conversation,
help them be patient
because there is so much more to learn.